ok ich muss
servus sg zh ein ganz herzlich
willkommen zu einem hohen konzept dieses
konzept heißt handicap games und worum
es dabei geht ist erklärt euch jetzt mal
kurz da wird mal den handicap game
center games und zwei games mit einem
handicap gespielt das heißt mit einer
komplikation also in der sache dies
schwieriger macht und heute
zum beginn zu der ersten folge etwas
ganz besonderes ausgedacht ich werde
heute so gern spielen mit den beiden
menschen der titel größe und nach jedem
pfiff liegestützen machen dafür habe ich
meine zweite kameraperspektive besorgt
die können dich billig ist bei blende
mal schauen
dafür habe ich mein mitbewohner lorenz
am spitze danke an dich und ja mit der
wahl heute trane ley und code freeze
hier was geht ab die werden mich
beschützen wenn ich dann meine
sportlichen aktivitäten machen und da
will ich sagen sie mache sich so leute
da sind wir der runde es geht gleich los
es geht los und ich bin richtig richtig
aufgeregt ich darf natürlich jetzt die
verpackten ich muss auch die kirche zu
holen
dann müsste sie unterhaltsam wird aber
dass man meine jungs dabei einfach
mittel dann aufs dach hoch oder die
stimme auftakt da oben ist direkt ein
wer ich habe eine art mal kurz halt
einfach in die eher zufällig
ok kannst mir stellte steinzeit geben
die holz aktie
du hast du hast ein bisschen versorgt
sehr gut war und ist mein erstes opfer
gegeben jetzt mal drauf alter der iss zu
gehörst du glücklich aber der hier aus
den boxen ok ok erst ist es ekel ist
geht los
das ist sehr gut ich hatte so warte
warte ich habe ja ok nächste warum
rüstung maximal ok gemacht dinge hätten
hinterher ingolstadt hinter unserer
umdrehen ein paar
okay der des kempinski als jetzt erklärt
den gewinn ich da hinten drin so ich bin
dollar 44 herzen vier herzen behalten da
da ging auf denen die rennen alle wieder
weg die rennt weg diesen kriterien ist
denn los mit denen so ok ok nächster
gegner ist weil so viele leute wie das
läuft richtig gut nicht dass es so gut
läuft die gerne runden richtig guter
mitspieler
der code freeze schickt ihn auf jeden
fall ab dessen beschreibung da hinten
die leute hier sind in der runde sind
wenn sich so ein up lachen wenn sie
sehen was hier passiert ist so sorg
weiter weiter weiter ps3 fans haben
lange nicht okay okay okay ich hab mir
mal den haag hier
okay okay meinte michael ich muss noch
das okay der handel nicht ausgestanden
ist gestartet
nein krass aber richtig gut heute
richtig gut ich habe jetzt auch gelernt
haben wir machen auf jeden fall noch in
kurzen hat man sehen und gleich wieder
leute so leute da sind wir wieder eine
sache die ich vergessen hat zu sagen die
changes werden selbstverständlich von
euch bestimmt
das heißt ihr könnt in die kommentare
schreiben welche change ihrem nächsten
video sehen wollt dann könnt ihr so
kreativ sein wie ihr wollt denkt euch
sachen aus seid kreativ schreibt die in
die kommentare und verfolgen viele
kommentare damit ich mir da die beste
aussuchen kann
wenn ihr wollt nehmt euch euren namen
wenn ich eure challenge auswählen wie
ihr bock habt jeden fall geht es hier
weiter auf sowie games 66
das ist ein ziemlich guter anfangs lukas
gekriegt hast du warst kriegt man die
markanten endrohren bleiben hatte
wer weiß das schon so sterben sollte ich
meine hand mama muss mich mal wussten ja
von henry horn
denn schon so und so es hat deine letzte
stündlein geschlagen
du bist völlig immer so sagt ok erster
keller pumpen pumpen
der rasenmäher
schlag mich kriegt ja noch
verfolgungswahn hier komm wir gehen
runter an den strand hier mit der gang
am rocken so ja weil wir nämlich
wegpusten richtig krasser typ
ach jetzt kann man ja aber nicht mehr so
locker sie runter springen nicht so
optimal aber ich bin so verhindert war
das knapp war das knapp
das war nicht so schlau und ich schon
genug ich glaube schon oder
hier wurde als gute denke die du noch
nicht genug
schau mal kurz kurz weiter hinten in die
kisten rein aber krass ich hab drei
herzen drei das ist der abgestürzte
bringen wurde noch nicht genug wir
können nicht sofort entscheiden
genau ich gehe mal richtung daun mit
einem wasser bot wo marco den abgrund
okay das ganze zelt ertrunken
denn ach stimmt ihr habt ihr mich
rausgeholt
loske box echt all dem was sie für chefs
fällt da habe ich überhaupt nichts
angehabt haft ansage wurde getötet
er hatte die tat mir richtig viel spaß
ich bin wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
verschoben interface cam bitte ich jetzt
zu entschuldigen
ob ihr recht auf dem schiff jemand ist
erhält er nicht so schnell ich bin fett
und langsam so schnell rennen ja ich
glaub da ist keiner
wir müssen noch weiter gehen ja ich habe
auch glück gehabt dass dieser marke
jetzt nicht so viele fehler hatte
krass ach ja eine sache die ich
vergessen habe schöne grüße an lennart
hier vom fußballspielen letztens weißt
du bescheid ob ich nicht eingetroffen
auch hier drei er gern geil los geht's
dahinter und die hinter uns lieber
hinter dir ja okay nicht warte warte ich
muss ich muss kurz mal hier ich töte ihn
dann ok ok ok geht das geht dass wir das
ich muss wohl richtig machen kann ich
machen kann ich machen
leute ich hole mir doch ich mache dann
einfach die zehn wenn ich jetzt genau
nach köln
bolt aber viel spaß gemacht wo ich kann
mir schwer machen ich kann mir dirk
machen private dennis bist du da ja ok
damit schützen wir kurz
na ja ich mache hier den kranken jetzt
für ich jetzt mit meinem leben hat den
feuerzeug tja besser gehütet einmal kann
der kann ich mir viel aushalten kann ich
mir viel aushalten kann ich nicht mehr
viel aushalten
ob long distance race job mache aber
nicht treffe ich nicht von mir
man muss ein bisschen näher an mich
darauf spekulieren dass sie fehler beim
laufen weit weg neue junge der ist echt
wird schon als nachfolger den bogen auf
zwei und packen können wir ein bisschen
um so jetzt bin ich froh wenn ich hätte
mir auch ein schwert greifen können
rein theoretisch aber es ist kein
graffiti hier wo ist der ist er hier
oben gegangen
ja enthalten in eschborn und nach denen
die erschwert ob es reicht noch von
derzeit 30 sekunden glaube ich nicht
dass im deathmatch machen ich habe
keiner im deathmatch keine ahnung da
macht ein 14 ist ob er mich so über mich
sieht ob er mich sieht
okay sie gerade die handy aufnahme ist
abgepackt deswegen würde ich sagen wir
spielen diese runde einfach noch so
fertig leute und falls euch die change
bisher gefallen hat dann lasst auf jeden
fall einen daumen nach oben da wenn ihr
mehr davon sehen wollte und ich würde
sagen ich hab mir hat richtig spaß
gemacht wir lassen sich hier natürlich
ausklingen
woher weiß nämlich überhaupt nicht mit
der bürste junge ja jetzt mich mich da
rein snacken ein bisschen ruhiger
listiger kleiner mensch den hole ich mir
ziemlich egal was ich da mache ich würde
mir okay alles klar
so ein quatsch
wie kann man sich noch in den namen
packen halt da ganz ehrlich so der sohn
und der ist so klug und ich hab's doch
geworden so weiter das ist die beste
beste aufhören würde ich jemals hatte
richtig geil also hat ihr wisst nicht
wirklich gefallen hat einen daumen nach
oben da lassen die nächsten handicaps in
die kommentare schreiben
natürlich sagen sie mal zum nächsten
video wieder wenn ihr die beiden jungs
in der beschreibung abgecheckt
holzhäuser und trainer bei diesem sinne
haut rein war richtig groß anzustrengen
aber es hat spaß gemacht
machs gut und scharf